Dave here and this is Rueben report I've
been really inspired by the reaction to
the interview with Sam I knew that I
felt really passionately about the
issues we talked about and needed to
address the campaign to discredit him
and I knew a lot of other people felt
the same way but I think I actually
underestimated just how badly people
wanted this conversation to happen from
YouTube comments to the tweets to people
who wrote me literally pages of thoughts
on Facebook and email there was a real
sense that it was cathartic for people
who were feeling the same thing I was
that's exactly what I want this show to
be so I'm really proud that we got off
to the right start if we're gonna build
some kind of community here based on the
principles that I laid out last week and
put in action in the interview with Sam
I think I have to ask something of you
now many of you were giving me kudos for
having an honest dialogue but if we
really want to change things it's gonna
have to be way bigger than just me I'm
sure some of you know that I'm gay
actually I got gay married two weeks ago
which is pretty gay it's pretty much the
gayest thing you can do
I don't really bring it up anymore
unless it's related to something in the
news and I don't want any extra credit
for it or anything like that
we got equality there's still work to do
but we've done great things that are
moving forward that's how progress is
supposed to work a couple years ago I
hosted a podcast in a Sirius XM show
called the six pack it was a pop culture
a new show with celebrity guests aimed
at the LGBT community the show was
really different than most gay culture
out there and that it was hosted by two
guys who just happened to be gay but we
didn't make everything about being gay I
mentioned this because we used to get a
ton of email from people saying how much
we were helping them come to terms with
themselves come out of the closet talk
to friends and family and all that stuff
even more than that though we got a ton
of email from people saying they were
still closeted and our show was their
only gay outlet one day this strange
paradox hit me the people that we were
helping the most by doing the show the
people who were closeted and had no
other outlet were the same people who
helped us as a show the least and that
they couldn't tweet about us or share
posts about us on Facebook or even tell
their friends about us I really
struggled with this in my relationship
to the audience because I knew that
closeted life all too well and I know
that if the situation had been reversed
I would have been one of those people
like I said before I think we're on to
something really special here we're
going to be part of something that takes
back liberalism for true liberals
but to do that we have to be louder we
have to be braver and bolder to say what
we think and share it with the people we
know I noticed a lot of the people with
the word atheism in their usernames have
anonymous profiles on Twitter and some
even on Facebook we all of our reasons
and I'm not passing judgment on anyone
here but think about that for a woman in
2015 atheists are one of the last groups
of people that feel like they have to be
anonymous when they say what they really
feel again this isn't everybody or even
the majority but it seems to be a bigger
portion than it should be and believe me
I get it I was closeted for a long time
you might have family that won't accept
you as an atheist or maybe your
community won't or maybe you aren't
fully sure what you are I don't want to
make this just about atheists though I
think all of us secular people have to
be seen and heard more let's not just
talk about it with each other let's get
other people in on the conversation too
we don't need to go out and find
converts they'll find us because that's
what humanism and secularism does by
default we just have to be louder it's
not going to be easy all three of the
people who Sam and I talked about who
continuously misrepresent him have done
so again publicly since our interview
feel free to check out my Twitter feed
to see the latest nonsense these people
are simply not going to stop if we want
to be heard we have to clearly fight
back with logic on our side so if you
hear me if you dig what we've started
here and you want it to get bigger and
better then like share comment post and
do whatever the hell else there is the
forces of anti-intellectualism and
radicalism are always on the march let's
get our voices heard so that we can win
not by violence but by ideas remember as
obi-wan said to Luke the force is what
gives a Jedi his power it's an energy
field created by all living things it
surrounds us and penetrates us it binds
the Galaxy together but if you don't
post about it on Facebook nobody will
know
Cara Santa Maria is the host and
producer of the talk nerdy podcast
co-host of the skeptics guide to the
universe LA area Emmy award-winning
reporter for SoCal connected on KCET and
science correspondent for tech now on al
Jazeera America but most importantly
she's my friend Kara welcome to the show
hey man your resume is blowing up huh
getting kind of crazy you got a lot of
stuff going on all sciency stuff and you
are my science II girl I'm gonna go too
yeah you are Mike go do so I thought
you'd be a perfect second guest at my
show because you know we had Sam Harris
on last week also a scientist
also a scientist actually like really a
scientist I'm not really a scientist
like Sam is is he more of a scientist d
yeah Sam Sam actually finished the PhD
he took time off to write his first book
but then he actually went back and
finished I took time off and just kept
taking time off so I got the masters
yeah but you're my science girl I know
that's communicator all right you are a
science communicator so that's where I
wanted to start actually cuz right under
your name right now it says science
communicator so what is a science
communicator you know I think more than
anything is just a catch-all term that a
lot of people in my profession use so it
could mean that you communicate science
as an author maybe you're a blogger
maybe you give talks maybe you do what I
do which is more in front of the camera
work or even some production work behind
it so sometimes it takes a more
journalistic flair sometimes it takes
more of an entertainment flair and those
are two very different camps but it all
falls within that science communication
umbrella I mean the main goal is to help
communicate scientific principles to the
public help improve science literacy and
do a little bit of translation because
sometimes scientists aren't very good at
liaison with the public sometimes
they're amazing and I love that
sometimes they need a little bit of help
and so that's that's where people like I
come in right and I think sometimes
people on my side of it need help and
that's why I always bring you on to
clean up some of the scientific messes
I'm better at and English but you you
help me clean up some that stuff
so obviously we have some of our old
audience that's gonna hear have heard
some of what we're gonna do here but we
have a whole bunch of new people that I
think are gonna really dig this so I
want to get to the science stuff later
but I wanna start with atheism sure
because you're also my main atheist
human Jacqueline Glenn are my two main
atheists so first off why don't we do
some basic definitions here this might
be tough it's gonna be tough I think you
can handle a theism yeah so I mean
technically agnosticism
is if you just break down the word it's
not knowing right a lot of people
self-identify as agnostics if they say
I'm not sure if there's a greater power
I'm not sure what happens after you die
and I don't want to hedge any bets now I
personally think that the label agnostic
is redundant because you know whether
you're a theistic or theistic whether
you're a believer or a non-believer I
said those backwards nobody knows if you
claim to know like you're full of [ __ ]
you know you know things I don't know
you don't have powers I don't have I
don't the people who scream about it the
most they usually seem to know the least
yeah actually there are some studies
that that confirm that so so I think of
myself as an agnostic or I'm sorry an
atheistic agnostic and some people are
theistic agnostics meaning that I you
know don't factor God into my daily life
I simply do not believe that God exists
well how do you have morals morals I
know you to be a pretty moral pretty
forthright person and I how do you
that's very nice of you to say but but
how do you navigate the sort of moral
divide if you're not getting it from
from some old book with some numbers
right because I was raised Mormon too
let's not forget oh we're getting to
that and then I left the church so not
only I'm like more of a heathen I'm kind
of the worst criminal within the
church's viewpoint because I actually
accepted Jesus was baptized and then
rejected it which is way worse than
never having it to begin with right
where do I get morals I get morals from
literature I get morals from ethics
courses I get morals from you know
empathy I get morals from interacting
with people and looking at their
struggles and and trying to put myself
in people's shoes and trying to
understand the human experience I mean
we are innately empathetic creatures we
are innately
moral creatures and the more that we can
kind of embrace others the more that we
can try to I think remove the us them
paradigm which is also very human and
it's also very difficult to push past
but the more that we do that I think the
more that we can live these moral lives
and a lot of people want to say that
morality is sort of a an outcome of
religion perhaps a religion is an
outcome of morality sure there are
correlations between the two but as I
often say when we talk about science
correlation does not imply causality
there's no way to prove that without
religion we wouldn't have or that you
know that yeah without religion we
wouldn't have a moral compass and it's
actually pretty philosophically
ludicrous to think in those terms right
so okay so you are from Texas as you
just said you grew up Mormon so in the
Mormon Church when did you come out yeah
so if I'm remembering correctly I came
out when I was around 15 years old and
it was you consider it like coming out I
mean how did the identity girl Cara how
did she feel about like actually having
to say this thing and that's the thing I
actually had to say it because I wasn't
I didn't grow up in kind of a sort of
religious household I grew up in a very
traditional Mormon household so I I
remember telling my father I had been
questioning for a while and he had been
giving me kind of the Pat responses of
like you know pray about it and whatever
you'll figure it out on your own
sure and when it I would pray about it
and nothing would happen and then I was
like what am i doing I finally remember
telling my father you know I don't
believe I don't believe and I feel like
I'm lying myself going to church every
Sunday every Wednesday every day before
school going to seminary it was a huge
part of my life and it felt like a big
ruse I think much like somebody who is
in the closet and who is struggling
trying to act straight or trying to be
somebody that they're not and so I
remember telling him and I remember
these words as long as you live under my
roof I have a moral obligation to God to
force you to go to church until you're
18 years
Wow so what do you do with that as a 15
year old I didn't live under his roof
anymore really it was a big choice you
know my parents had long been divorced
and at 15 I remember saying to him you
know technically I think I'm of an age
of consent where if we went to the
courthouse and I pled my case that a
judge would say she can stay with her
mom full-time it's her choice she's you
know she's old enough to make these
kinds of decisions and I was a pretty
precocious kid I'm sure I could have
convinced the judge that I had thought
about this quite a bit which I had and
so my father said okay he let me make
that choice it was a difficult bind to
be in and I didn't talk to him for many
years after that Wow our relationship
took a big hit and yeah it took a long
time for us to get back on good terms
yeah so there's two really different but
interesting pieces to that because
there's the choice that you made in your
own life to say this is who I am but
then there's this other piece of it's
not easy for it for a 40 year old to say
to their parent I don't believe in what
you believe much less a 15 year old sure
it's maybe it's even easier for a 15
year old because you're like rebellious
at that point anyway I mean I'm not sure
but that definitely I look back at the
gravity of that decision and I think
like whoa that was pretty bold of me
yeah I'm not sure if I felt that way at
the time yeah how do you separate one of
the things we talked with Sam about a
lot was separating the doctrine of
something from the people that follow it
so in the case with Sam it was mostly
about the doctrine of Islam versus
Muslim people so how do you know after
the experience that you had with your
father believing what you believe your
whole career really is is very much
based in this how do you separate the
doctrine of Mormonism I'm sure you have
many other family members that you love
that are great people and all that how
do you separate that from the piece of
you that says I just don't believe in
any of it yeah you know I think it's
it's for me it's easy to separate for my
own life right like I can look at
Mormonism and I can look at my beliefs
and I can say that's [ __ ] and I
don't believe in it yeah but of course
there are people that I love who are
like hook line and sinker they buy into
it
and it's one thing to step back and say
you know they bought into [ __ ] but
it's another thing to actually say I
still respect these people in their will
and yeah you know I don't come yes I
come from Texas I don't come from like
rednecks
you know my mother who's no longer more
men is an educator she's a schoolteacher
recently retired my father who still is
very much Mormon is an engineer and his
wife who is also very much Mormon is a
science teacher a very good science
teacher and so these are educated people
who promote education and who are very
good parents adopted you know adult not
adult but teenage children after we had
moved out of the house like incredible
people yeah and I love them dearly but
we have a big disconnect when it comes
to belief now I don't think they need to
believe what I believe for us to get
along and vice-versa it's one thing when
you're in a parental child situation the
rules are a bit different
but it is still tough because I think
one of the things that you take with you
no matter how long after the
reconciliation happens is a bit of pity
a bit of like I I know in my heart of
hearts that I kind of feel sorry that
they live this lifestyle sorry for them
that they're sort of enslaved to these
religious rules yeah I feel sorry for
them that they have to struggle with big
issues like accepting homosexuality in
the family for example and their Church
teaches them that this is an abomination
and it's so ingrained in them but I know
they must struggle feeling like but but
I love this person how could that person
be an abomination
those I feel sorry for the the
completely religiously inundated that
that pity for you to like they would
look at you and go well she doesn't have
these incredibly powerful beliefs
oh yeah my dad thinks I'm not going to
heaven yeah like well yeah exactly and
not especially not the celestial and the
terrestrial heaven gets super
complicated an apartment faith right but
yeah of course he feels sorry for me he
thinks I'm not gonna bathe in God's
glory for all of eternity
that's like a pretty big deal to
somebody who actually believes that
exists and you're not doing it just as a
private person you're doing it as very
very publicly and alone and interacting
with a lot of people and potentially
influencing people and you know it's I'm
a heretic and that's you know probably
not something he's
proud of why do you think atheists are
so hated I've seen poll after poll and
we've talked about them and some other
shows that atheists are the most
distrusted group in America people would
never vote for an atheist to be
President you know Barney Frank who came
who was a congressman from Massachusetts
a pretty liberal place came out as gay
and something like 1983 didn't come out
as an atheist until he was on Real Time
with Bill Maher after he had retired and
since then has even backtrack a little
bit on saying that he was an atheist
what is it about atheist because the
Atheist that I know are pretty much by
and large the most decent sort of
humanistic open people yeah that I know
and yet there's this portrayal of them
that's completely the reverse I don't
think it's that people think that
atheists have like horns or anything you
know I'm there I think there's there's
racism and there's xenophobia and
there's hate and there's fear and
there's all of the different things that
feed into why people don't trust or
don't like what they don't understand I
think specifically though with atheists
you have to put yourself in the shoes of
the religious to understand where this
hatred comes from because of course
non-religious people don't have any
problem with religious people running
for often office it's religious people
right I'm sorry non-religious people
don't have any problem with atheists
running for office it's religious people
that have a problem with that
and think about okay so for example you
are an upstanding gay man and there are
moments do you have your moments and
there are some religious people who
think that you are just yeah right who
think that like like being gay is
disgusting like a Edward falzone's book
because that's what the Bible teaches
and so they have these ideas in their
head that your lifestyle is an
abomination and blah blah blah and it is
a choice and you could have chosen to
live another way but you're still a
person and you're a flawed person and
you've made a difficult choice and maybe
you can come back around I think that
there's something that really speaks to
the core of the structure of belief that
an atheist is somebody who actively
rejects the foundation of what matters
to these people yeah and
and that act is so closely tied to what
they think of as the devil what they
think of as evil what they think of as
you know heresy all of these pure just
irrationally fearful States its apostasy
it's it's what fuels Isis right it's
it's worse than being an Islamic
apostate it's worse than being a
Christian apostate it's being an atheist
right it's the ultimate it's the
ultimate apostasy and I think that
that's really where it comes from and
because of that historically generation
after generation I think we get a bad
rap so you've got some people who are
such deep believers that there's no way
they're gonna come around to it and then
you've got other people who just equate
the word atheism yeah with like I don't
know just like bad stuff like they're
criminals they're they're just like bad
dude right so I want to get to New
Atheism yeah but do you think the other
piece of this is that to me it seems
like because an atheist can come from
any religious background be any sex be
any sexuality be any nationality all
those things that in a weird way what
they fear is that this group of people
is coming together using sort of the
best of all of us you know you mean like
they like that they think that it's sort
of like for gay people there are gay
people of every nationality and
ethnicity and religion and all that and
that's why there's so much richness I
think in the gay community and I'm
starting to think that that's what
people fear about atheists too because
there's lacking of these white atheists
but see this is something that I think
intrinsic and what you just said the the
gay community like the Atheist community
it exists all right yeah it exists but
not to the same extent because I think
there's something that's sort of
fundamental to being an atheist that
makes some people reject trying to find
community sure the whole point is that
we're not a church the whole point is
that we just don't believe it's not that
we all believe the same thing is that we
have a lack of belief and I think that
by definition that makes some people
feel like we don't need to band together
there is no common thread here it's just
the default state all right so that's
exactly where I wanted to go with this
because new atheist that seems to be the
new thing so do you have a definition
for new atheist I can I can sort of tell
you what I think but I don't know
I mean I think that new atheist is a
term that's often used by non new
atheists so it's sort of a derogatory
term so I'm not really sure how to
define it because it seems like from the
outside people apply that label
who knows maybe I'm a new atheist I
don't know I do know that the term
firebrand atheist is one that's actually
kind of welcome within that community so
david silverman who is the president of
American Atheists he has a new book
coming out actually wrote the foreword
to his book which is really funny
because he's a hardcore firebrand
atheist and I'm like not at all
but I like that he is one because I
think it takes all types right and I go
by firebrand oh you mean like really
outspoken oh yeah like he doesn't think
you can be an atheist Jew right like he
thinks you need to drop the Jew side
because how can you be both an atheist
and a Jew you have to you know hold on
to your a theists values and you have to
be very open about it like we talked
about this at length on my podcast and
I'm like of course you can be anything
needs Sam Harris last week who's the one
of the biggest atheist I know that but
yeah I mean one of my best friends is an
atheist year when I get it like and he's
super Jewish then super atheist yeah and
so I'm not a firebrand atheist I am
really kind of accepting of people's
religious beliefs and I think that we
need a spectrum of more secular values
if we want to move the goalposts but I
think it's important that there are
firebrand atheists the same way that I
think that it's important that when you
look at feminism that there are men who
hold on to feminist ideals that there
are women who are out loud and proud and
in front of the line talking about it
and then there are women who act in a
feminist way but who don't make it their
mission to always you know be that
feminist same thing with black lives
matter across the spectrum you need the
people that are out in front that are
that are being loud that are making sure
that people pay attention to this
movement but you also need the people
who quietly live their lives that way
every day it's almost like we should
have a broad spectrum of people who have
been different things and can all still
get along and exactly truth is if you
have atheists of all these different
flavors then I think that you're going
to see more people being affected more
people that are afraid to come out
saying that person is just like me or I
seem
myself in that person and I can look at
them as a role model if we were all one
flavor we would turn off a huge section
of the popular yeah and I think to sort
of wrap this up I think that's sort of
the people that and I unfortunately it
happens to be a lot of people on the
left that have been attacking new
atheist my friend kuklinski said that a
new atheist to him is just an atheist
that finally is saying I'm an atheist
because atheists used to have to just
not say anything and when I see these
people on the Left attacking new atheist
as if new atheists have some set of
beliefs all they have is this one thing
in common which is not belief not not a
bigger set and I you know I remember
dating somebody previously who I think
was a little confused about my atheism
but it was probably agnostic himself and
I remember him saying something about
like I just don't understand why you
have to be so public about it I don't
understand it's a private matter why are
yours and it's such a double standard
he's like are you kidding me
religious people are like the most
public people about their religion and
the fact that I want to say vocally I'm
an atheist I don't believe in God I
don't factor God into my decision-making
I don't believe in any afterlife I don't
believe in anything supernatural I'm a
science-based evidence-based thinker the
reason I do that is because then if I
continue to live my life the way that I
hope I'm living it in a moral way in an
upstanding way then people can look and
go oh that's what an atheist looks like
oh I've been really inspired the last
couple weeks and I've been noticing this
over of course they're probably about
six months or so I sense a real
awakening by secular people not just
atheists I mean people that are secular
in that they can have whatever belief
that they want but they want our public
space our politics and our public life
to have nothing to do with religion do
you do you sense this please tell me yes
that there's been some kind of awakening
so like constitutionalist so like people
who are coming back around to 250 years
ago yes no I definitely think so I think
that it does come from more people being
willing to say that their non-religious
it's the largest growing minority in the
country and so even though people who
self-identify as atheists are still the
most hated group and trusted less than
rapists is totally crazy right
people who are not religious are growing
in numbers and I think they're growing
in solidarity and even religious people
who are saying are standing up for
secular values and saying we need to
promote a separation of church and state
and we need to move away from the
Christian privilege that is like under
light or political structure for way too
long does it always strike you as odd
that it seems to me the religious right
on one hand they always scream about
separation of church and state and then
they're the same ones that are always
pushing religion into the conversation
do they really scream of us I guess they
do
I don't very much I know you could
something you know real quick saying
like Kim Davis and Huckabee where he was
telling people that she shouldn't abide
by a law that she doesn't believe in do
people actually yes that's combining
church and state I was giving them a
little more favor and also I feel like
it's just a quick aside with this whole
key Davis thing why do people care it's
it it's one just like this is like the
plane crash over and over and over right
like this is really no bearing on it if
anything this one woman is emblematic of
how much this movement is dying yeah you
know the fact that there's only one
person that they can point to and that
everybody's rallying around her and it's
a joke it's become such an eye roll and
it to me it's actually a good thing
because it's showing me that it's
becoming more and more marginalized and
we we don't have to take them serious
well yeah you know I completely agree I
think I've sent two tweets on the whole
Kim Davis thing which normally it would
be like one of my wheelhouse thing but
it seems to me it's like we've won this
one we've won right there's nothing that
Mike Huckabee can do reverse this no
even if god forbid he became president
irony yeah he won't digging himself like
he's doubling down on a non-issue that's
embarrassing that it's laughable and I
think that the more that we put her in
the spotlight and the more that we you
know we do the wall-to-wall CNN coverage
about her the more it gives this false
sense of legitimacy that just doesn't
exist right it's like the media is
blowing it up to be this thing where
actually the average
person is like you know what this this
is a dying dinosaur right here yeah
she's she's a monologue joke that's all
she is you know so one more on this sort
of broad topic so again I had I had Sam
on last week and it's been really
interesting for me to see what happens
when someone with a background in
science gets involved in politics and I
almost think that the if I have one
critique of Sam it would be that he's
placed himself in this really precarious
position out of his own bravery and as
he said it was at huge cost to him
probably personally and professionally I
would imagine do you think it's hard for
scientists or should people of a science
background get involved in the political
debate because it seems he's too in a
lot of ways he's too smart to be talking
about the way we talk about politics
because politics is so dumbed down
ie Donald Trump is leading in the
Republican polls and it's a binary right
there's no room for nuance in political
debate especially not in the eight
second sound bites that we've grown used
to and in political media
I don't know I'm of two minds about this
so I am a co-host on the skeptics guide
to the universe which is a popular
science podcast that really celebrates
skepticism evidence based thinking
debunking you know medical quackery and
things like that and the host Stephen
novella is you know a renowned
neuroscientist and a renowned skeptic
and he has an edit he has made an
editorial decision on this show over the
past ten years which I just joined like
two months ago that we don't discuss
politics that that's not relevant to the
scientific conversations now on my
podcast I talk about politics all the
time sure because I think that science
is not just a topic that you study it's
not just facts and figures in a textbook
but it's a way of thinking and it's a
way of utilizing the principles of the
scientific method and looking at
evidence in order to make informed
decisions and so for me scientific
thinking is the foundation of politics
and if we could start moving into a into
kind of a direction where this country
is governed based on evidence and not
based on as Colbert calls it truthiness
right which is so often what we do
Edge's Latian is passed because it gives
you a gut check right or because there's
pork or you know all those other reasons
financial you know incentives and things
like that but so often we make strong
legislative decisions where there's
evidence available to us and we don't
base it on the evidence and I think that
if we started moving more in that
direction we'd have a much more
functional government and definitely a
more functional economy and so I would
like to see more scientists moving into
the political arena but I can see why it
would be disconcerting if you are a
functioning university scientist because
you also oftentimes receive federal
money sure
and so then things start to get a little
bit confusing about where your
allegiance lies now Sam is not a
university scientist he was a trained
academic but it doesn't work as an
academic he's an author he does
political punditry now I mean it's part
of his job and I applaud him for that
even though you see this he's on a hit
list I'm sure you don't hit list because
of this you know it's a choice that he
made and I think it's a really brave
choice but yet I have no doubt he's on
hit list like my Twitter feed from today
it's exactly so GMOs we backed about
GMOs before can you give me like a five
minute sort of GMO 101 yeah well free
you said you just say GMO people freak
out they go Monsanto and everyone goes
now and lately there's this added
confusion because of scientists who I've
interviewed many times across multiple
platforms named Kevin Fulton has been in
the news a lot because of a FOIA request
that revealed some things that people
didn't want to see mostly things that he
never denied anyway yeah but and it
wasn't a lot of money that he got and
all that but yeah it's get complicated
but but regardless of that if we're
gonna talk about the core of GMOs these
other conversations really are
irrelevant to this core conversation so
literally 101 sure focus know if you
don't know anything about yeah so what
is it GMO well technically the word
genetically modified organism could
refer to anything any organism anything
that's alive in which the genes have
been modified so basically breeding two
plants together to try and get a desired
trait is technically GMO now that's not
how we casually use the word anymore we
usually use the term GMO to actually
refer to transgenic organism so these
are organisms where
they weren't selectively bred for
particular traits but there was actually
a trans gene that was inserted we've
gone into the laboratory we've tested
and we found these genetic markers these
areas where we can do something to the
plant generally we're talking about
plants there are some animals that are
up for FDA approval like salmon mm-hmm
but generally we're talking about plants
and scientists will say for example this
is a big one right now citrus greening
is wiping out oranges in Florida wiping
them out they're all really sick it's
getting harder and harder to get fresh
oranges and this is a problem that they
don't see going away can we make oranges
that are resistant to this disease
because if we don't we may not have
oranges anymore so the scientists work
very hard to go into the genome to try
and understand all of these different
genes within the plant and try and
modify them in a certain way sometimes
it involves taking a gene from another
plant and inserting it sometimes it
involves turning a gene on silencing a
gene making a gene do something that
maybe it wouldn't have done unless it
was under pressure there's a lot of
different ways that you can genetically
modify a plant these are things we've
done for a long time for all kinds of
different plans oh yeah
and there are literally thousands of
research versions of GMOs but there are
very few GMOs that are on the market and
I think that's another big misconception
people you'll see you know labels on
crazy stuff like you'll see labels on
potatoes that are like GMO free and it's
like well yeah cuz there's no such thing
as a GMO food today like they're not
modifying it to stop either bugs from
eating I mean they were in the lab but
you can't buy it yet so the thing is the
only crops that are available are mostly
big AG crops so corn is is genetically
modified probably most of the corn that
you eat soybeans sugar beets papaya is
genetically modified a genetically
modified Apple just came on the market
or it's about to I think it's the
Okinawa Apple that and it doesn't brown
you can take a bite out of it on the
table and do it did you try it it tastes
like an apple and you didn't like grow
some weird I did not we you know you've
eaten a lot of GMOs in your day I don't
see any appendages that aren't supposed
to be there
oh you can't see alright so from that
very sort of simplistic explanation of
where GMOs
why do so many people hate GMOs because
people are afraid of what they don't
understand and there's a lot of
misinformation out there and so there
are some legitimate concerns when it
comes to environmental consequences I
think probably the most legitimate
concern when it comes to GMOs is the is
a normal outcome of evolution and I use
the example of superbugs with
antibiotics because I think it's a good
analogy so when we take antibiotics we
actually induce resistance in the bugs
that can infect us and now there are
whole classes of bugs that are resistant
to those antibiotics just like in GMO
plants when you alter them to resist
certain pests or to resist mostly with
the pests when you alter them to resist
those pests you may have new pests that
Deval that evolve a resistance to that
resistance you see it a little bit with
weeds too like the glyphosate argument
which is roundup people are really
scared of Roundup BT is more the pest
thing and the glyphosate is more of the
the weed thing well sometimes you mix
those things up that sort of whatever
Monsanto gets involved but we'll cover
that another time sure sure we're
talking about you know the potential for
super weeds to grow because these plants
are are helping them grow it's it's a
natural process and it doesn't just
happen in GM it happens anytime that
you're doing large-scale agriculture and
so I like to say to people you know
would you want to take all the
antibiotics off the market because
they're making antibiotic resistant no
we need to be smarter about how we use
them and we need to come up with new
antibiotics and so what scientists are
actually doing is they're trying to
figure out new and better ways to
improve resistance to these different
bugs let's say that there is a pesticide
inside of a plant and the bug it
develops resistance to that pesticide
well if you actually alter that plant in
two ways now you have two lines of
defense against this bug it's
statistically very unlikely that you'll
get a mutation in that bug against both
of those lines of resistance so now you
can have a resistant plant and you're
less likely to see resistance occurring
in the bug so you know scientists are
always trying to keep one step ahead of
nature and these are the biggest
problems that we're seeing with genetic
modification a lot of the problem
that people think are happening with
genetic modification cancer you know
health problems what's the big one seeds
blowing into another field and getting
sued for it
that's the months yes suicides in India
yeah
none of these are substantiated yeah
none of them the science shows time and
time again that these are not real
concerns and if you actually do dig into
the case law and you actually do try and
understand what has happened legally in
these situations most of those lawsuits
with the big AG companies involve people
storing seeds which is technically
against the law now if you have a
problem with you know patenting a scene
right again it's a hole or if you have a
problem with large-scale agribusiness
and you have a problem with the way that
we you know dry out the land by only
farming a very particular crop I get
that but that has nothing to do with
genetic modification and I think we
often conflate the issue yeah the topic
of abortion never seems to go away and I
want to talk to you as someone of
science and as an atheist who obviously
has no morals how how do you negotiate
this because it seems to me that people
on the Left when they talk about
abortion they make it sound like
everyone on the right hates women and
that they want to control women and when
people on the right talk about it they
make it sound like everyone on the left
hates babies right and neither one of
those things now that's very obvious so
how do you as someone that comes to
conclusions based on science how do you
navigate the sort of ethical I assume
you're pro-choice but actually I'm just
assuming that but is that no of course I
so how do you then as someone that's
pro-choice mm-hmm believes in evidence
believes in science how do you decide
where like do you think that it should
be a two-month cutoff for an abortion
where do you where do you come up with
that as someone that isn't coming from
the religious angle but is coming from
the science-based angle I'd say abortion
should be legal up until 12 years old
like until the brain is fully 25 you
know it's funny because I am an
evidence-based thinker I try to be an
evidence base
and a skeptical thinker and I try to
listen to the science first and then
make my political decisions based on
that so I am liberal yeah I am left-wing
I am progressive I think it's easy to
paint me in but I'm also super Pro vac
mandatory vaccinations I'm Pro GMOs
which is usually a more conservative
viewpoint so sometimes it's hard to put
me in a box now
I'm not pro like I am pro-life I hate
that term it makes it sound like I'm not
yeah I'm I am pro-choice not because
it's it's partially because of the
science and it's partially because I'm
not religious and I think that a lot of
pro-life ideology comes purely from
religion and once you take religion out
of the equation
it becomes a much more nuanced and
complicated topic I am pro-choice
meaning that I don't think that if a
woman wants to have an abortion she
shouldn't be able to and I don't think
that if a woman wants to keep her baby
she should be coerced to have an
abortion I think that a woman should be
able to make a decision based on her own
body and in my view which may sound kind
of extreme until that baby is born it's
hers it's her body right so I agree with
you I guess up until that point I'm
absolutely pro-choice but but about a
week before the birth I mean where ROM
an argument doesn't happen right it's
like it's like the voter ID stuff you
know like old voter fraud we got to be
careful about that women don't carry
babies to a weak determine the go I
think I'm gonna lose this baby it's a
book but so at three months when the
baby now has features and you know all
these things and I guess this is the
slip up to this point it's it's legal
first and second trimester abortions are
legal and I think that you have to look
at all this is the thing when you're
writing laws we have to think about not
just the obvious cases but the aberrant
cases this is why writing legislation is
actually a very you know it's a nuanced
and artistic endeavor and especially
then when you look at how you defend
laws in the courts right when you look
at case law it's complicated because we
have to fully understand all of the
times when the when the laws can be
misused or misinterpreted and there are
cases for example where a woman does not
know that she is pregnant
until well into her pregnancy and I
think you do have to take that into
consideration there are cases in which
women are victims of coercion or abuse
or sometimes it is more nuanced than
that maybe they feel pressure from their
husband their boyfriend or a member of
society to have a baby and they don't
realize until later that they do have
these options
maybe they fall on financially difficult
times maybe they find out that there's a
you know some sort of genetic
abnormality and the baby and that they
don't have the means to raise that baby
and I think that all of those really
complicated really emotional personal
questions have to be taken into account
I want to say and it may be it's easy
for me to say because I don't have kids
but the woman is the vessel and she is
carrying this child and until the child
comes out of her it is her body it is
her choice and they are her rights and I
do think that it's a complicated topic
and I think that that's why it's
important that we do talk about it and I
know and I almost regret having said the
part about the one week before birth
because I know it is a straw man and
it's not something that happens but I
think there's something interesting
about the when is it really a feasible
life thing that and obviously we can't
resolve that now and I think that we
have to think about every possible
option because even religious people
you'll you'll find that whereas they
would be appalled if they got knocked up
and had abortion they might go get IVF
which some religions don't even allow
that but they might get IVF and of
course they're gonna do selective
reduction during IVF is that not
abortion and then review I mean it's
very complicated yeah because you know
sometimes you do IVF and like five of
them stick yeah and then you turn into
Jill and Kate Plus so I guess the most
extreme religious people even in those
cases look at look at a baby as a
blessing from God it's almost like
people pick and choose when to believe
in religion all right so one more for
you
what I want to do with all these
interviews is sort of end on a very
personal note and we actually started on
a personal note because you talked about
leaving the church and very personal
things related to hold on so you have
talked about your battle or struggle
with depression
oh sure pretty pretty vocally
but I I know you pretty well over the
last three years it's not something that
we talk about a lot privately hey let's
talk about my depression yeah yeah it's
not actually a cheery topic well in that
way I know you to be totally like happy
and well-adjusted yeah whatever
most people who struggle with depression
are really good actors they don't they
are it's a coping mechanism that they
develop and that's not to say that like
every day of my life I'm pretending to
be happy because I experience joy and
experienced happiness on a regular basis
I'm also in treatment and I take
medication every day and that has made a
huge difference there have been periods
of my life where if you had seen me
which I would not have allowed you to
see me because I was very private you
know again we come up with our
strategies and we come up with our coat
coping mechanisms if we had been in a
position where you had seen me at my
lowest of lows yeah you wouldn't be
saying the same thing and so I think
that that's a common experience for
people who struggle with depression
there's a private side of your
depression and then there's a public
face if you're willing to have one which
might not many people are and I
completely understand that I personally
feel like I have a responsibility as
somebody who has a bit of you know
people tweet me people Facebook me they
they you know some people know that I
exist and and I've noticed that when I
do talk about this the feedback that I
get is really it just makes me feel good
it makes me feel good to know how many
people are out there who are struggling
with this and don't see that a lot of
people are talking about it publicly so
because of that I feel a real obligation
to do it
yeah is it depressing I guess that's an
odd choice of depression to present no
is it depressing to you or disconcerting
I suppose would be better worried that
we don't really have a mental health
discussion in this country anymore
I feel like maybe five years ago we
actually did a little bit people talked
about a little bit and now and I think
it was around when the shooting started
yeah but I don't think we do anymore
with the shootings we're not we're not
go into the gun thing and that's
obviously we need to have that
discussion but I worry that the mental
health thing is like a scapegoat for the
gun advocates so you have the gun Nutter
butters you're like
but it's not because of guns it's cuz he
was mentally ill and he shouldn't have
gotten I'm not saying that that's not
also a very important conversation have
but just like we should be having
conversations about gun control when
we're not in crisis right you know the
same thing like when you're having like
sexual problems at home yeah probably
not a good idea to talk about them when
you're both like naked and like it's
better to like wait until it's a more
calm situation whatever is going on
it's it's a safer time to talk about it
I think it's the same thing when it
comes to both gun control and mental
health like we should be talking about
this in the light and in the dark
because it's not really that helpful
when we're doing it only in crisis and I
think it also elevates and ignores the
day-to-day struggles that people have
you know depression is a massive illness
and it's a biological illness and it's
an illness that destroys lives and it is
so treatable the problem is that you
know in this country especially I think
with the older set we are getting better
just like with coming out as atheist we
are getting better with the younger
people erasing that stigma and being
more comfortable talking about it
the problem is we still treat
psychiatric illnesses like like
disorders of will and that's that's a
fundamental hurdle that we have to get
past that somehow you can will yourself
out of it that somehow you can change
your patterns of thinking just think
more positively yeah just do that and
you'll be well it's because people don't
understand the biological basis of these
issues and we've never treated
depression for example the same way that
we've treated diabetes you would never
shame somebody into needing insulin
right but we do we shame people who take
antidepressants with shame people who
have to take psychiatric medication and
that's just a huge bummer and I hate to
see young kids either being scared away
for it or feeling like they're not
allowed or scared away from it I'm sorry
or feeling like they're not allowed to
be honest with themselves and older
people - my father my father went
through a depressive episode and my
father has struggled with some things
and
remember when he finally told me when I
was struggling myself it was so
meaningful for me it helped me so much
oh oh so much is explained and then he
became this confidant and I could talk
to him about it but I had no idea what
he was going through it because he sort
of like this ocean yeah it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy almost the
shame then just continues the cycle
meanwhile you hear it from your father
and then it probably makes you feel
better in who you are well in the thing
I mean what you just said is so
important there's this negative feedback
when you're depressed like actually
physically experiencing a depressive
episode such a big portion of that is
guilt and shame and to have an added
layer of guilt and shame that comes from
society not understanding your
depression and then having to carry the
guilt of being depressed while you're
depressed it's insane it's impossible
and so I think the more that we become
open about it and the more that we
celebrate all of our differences and our
quirks and the more that we understand
that going to therapy is like something
that a lot more people should probably
do and and and being okay with that and
being okay with the fact that we all
have our issues you know what I mean and
we all struggle and I think it makes us
richer and it makes this more
interesting and it makes us more human I
don't know that's the world I want to
live in yeah that's the world I want to
live in I think we did a little talk
therapy here right how do you feel it's
definitely not the same
my shrink my shrink would probably not
like to hear that this was a therapy
session
yeah well worst part about you that was
a hell of an outro alright well Cara
of course is one of my favorite people
you can follow her it's Cara Santa Maria
come at Cara Santa Maria on Twitter do
you want to send them anywhere else
that's good that's good alright thanks
for watching everybody and we'll do it
again next
you